all right it's time for a very important
segment it's very personal for me and i
love doing these our love of food should
be simple
but it's our relationship with food that
can be so
complicated my mixed messages with food
started when i was a kid
this is hilarious and weird and kind of
sad but also
the truth my mom after every audition
that like wouldn't work or i would blow
would take me to mcdonald's
to get me a filet of fish and ironically
rejection was associated with these like
delicious creamy fatty foods
and paging dr freud creamy comfort food
is still my go-to
and my mom didn't do anything wrong it's
just that was like our tradition
and my whole life i've totally
fluctuated with my weight i have a
thousand pictures to prove it
and all i want to do is find the balance
and break
the cycle diet isn't dieting isn't fun
and over-indulging doesn't make you feel
great and i spoke to four women who also
share this struggle and we're finding
out together
how we can break the cycle
it's funny that this beauty and this
poetry
and the necessity of food is also tied
in
with like personal downfall do you
fluctuate like
five pounds or a couple meals and then
you get back on the horse because i am a
20 30 40 pounder fluctuating i am
i don't just fall off the wagon i fall
off the wagon
i derail the train i send it way over
the cliff on into the ocean
where we're currently sitting underneath
the titanic continually sinking
food for me gives me instant
gratification like
it satisfies something in me instantly
i'm a dancer and dancing you have to
learn it
it takes time and then you're satisfied
at the end
but with food it's that instant
gratification
and there's not really a result what are
you gonna celebrate i just had dinner
what is like a trigger for you
is it like a bad day is it seeing food
in a grocery store
there have been so many weeks and
and days where if i have the slice of
pizza
all right and now what's for dinner
because i'm gonna just double that
yeah the second that you have something
that you shouldn't have
i just go all in for me food was always
the solution like my grandma's like i'll
just make you dumplings and ice cream
or i'll make you some hot wings tonight
and it's like okay it was always her way
of making me feel better
i didn't see food as like a struggle
until the weight started coming
after having my son it got harder and
harder to lose weight
and then looking at myself in the mirror
it was kind of like
okay this body's never going to go back
to the way that it was so at this point
who cares
and you feel bad about yourself and you
put yourself down i do
um big extremes just yesterday i had a
stressful day
i find myself at the pizza shop a
big box just for me two slices
and i sat there and ate both slices
while sitting in the car
because i didn't want to take it home
and then everybody's looking at me like
was it worth it it was worth it during
that moment
and then afterwards i'm like i
recently had been ill and i'm sitting
there in bed watching
uh the biggest loser or my 600 pound
life eating
a five pound bag of peanut m m's of
course you know you can't throw that out
you have to finish that bag
well it doesn't close yeah they don't
close they say it's receivable but it
doesn't
and i'm sitting there and i'm watching
this and i'm fat-shaming myself
your mom i understand had diabetes
i understand that you just got a result
not a result that i'm
pre-diabetic which scares the messiah
because i have the six children
it's horrible it's um something that i
don't want
my kids to experience me going through
you know
when you're not taking care of yourself
and you're in an extreme you're
basically playing russian roulette with
your life
you really are and you know i can't
afford to do that anymore i have a
really
six lives depending on me
what or who is going to be worth it for
you
to break the cycle my son
at one point i realized i was being very
selfish he wasn't getting what he needed
from me
and i had to get myself together i think
breaking the cycle really starts with
loving yourself
do you love yourself i do
love myself it's me i have to learn how
to control stress because then that
triggers my stress eating
and it's finding the accountability i
have to be accountable to myself
and that you know that's where i
struggled with it
i had um a lot of big life changes in
the last few years
and i didn't handle it very well i went
right down
and i stayed down for a lot of years
and it was the same exact revelation
that you had
i realized i couldn't do anything
but figure out myself yeah it's an
ongoing process
i mean we could straight up be in like a
drug clinic here today literally
talking about like every single gateway
that just leads to
full-blown usage and
there is no sobriety for eating i
couldn't have had these conversations
years ago myself oh no we didn't talk
about it we you know
i would talk about it but i wouldn't fix
it yeah
now i want to break cycles i'm just
warning you
okay um listen i am
here with one of the incredible four
women that you just listened to
since that day dolores reached out to us
with a very exciting update
and she has lost 10 pounds in just a few
weeks
look at those pictures and by the way
i am in love with her hi delores
oh my god we're new bffs
yes i am so happy to see you and
i heard that you told jessica yank lunas
our producer
just tell us what you told her about how
this happened
well after being on the show with you i
you know
you get that light bulb moment and i
realized i'm like everything i just said
and what i discussed with you
i need to hold myself accountable i need
to
manage my stress better so i
you know started working out a little
bit more i had a little setback had
injured
my back before the gyms opened of course
so i have to now
work out in a different way so but i've
managed to
handle the stress of back to school and
the whole remote learning and whose
chromebook's not working
and i'm not sitting there at night
anymore
watching my 600 pound life eating peanut
m ms
i'm lucky because you come on twice a
day for me
so at 8 pm i'm watching you again
and i'm not eating my peanut m ms
you know one of the things that i find
so difficult
is i have tried those i just call it the
chicken and broccoli diet
because it just doesn't bring joy after
a while
you can do it for a few weeks but you
are setting yourself up for failure
life is about pleasure that's right and
it is about enjoying and when i look at
this fellaio fish
i brought you a bag of peanut m m's we
don't do those anymore
but what if we're able to enjoy them
a little bit because it's every once in
a while
should we try that yes do you want to
open your bag
sure because i'm desperate to eat this
what i really want to do with breaking
cycles
is stop with the extremes right because
the extremes
is what puts me in a very bad place if
you take
everything away from someone guess what
they want
the thing that's taken away my problem
with this
is that i overdo it and then i don't
feel good so then i cut it out
completely
and then i want it again yeah so
for me breaking the cycle means this
elusive
bee named balance and to be free
of the extremes that don't make me happy
and don't work for my body
i've been free i'm praying so good oh
this chocolate's so good
dolores do you think that
we can enjoy things here and there
by saying i've got a handle on this
yeah because if you take this stuff away
i'm only going to want it more
but if i eat it less then when i have it
i can enjoy it right you have to
be able to enjoy it and not binge on it
and be like
i haven't had it and just gobble it all
up if you
do it in moderation allow yourself
whether it's once a week once every two
weeks
um and not use it and not use it as a
reward
yes as not use it as a reward and do not
use it as
as a punishment that i'm punishing
myself for i screwed up so now i'm going
to
devour this whole bag in moderation
i think those are the extremes too it's
the mental game
of like i've got this i'm and how do you
feel
after 10 pounds you're wearing like an
air vey legere
like band-aid dress you are feeling good
dolores
will you stand up i mean
does this feel good enough to keep going
oh yes definitely i don't i am happier
um when i'm obviously thinner which is
something we were taught
growing up you know you could never be
too blonde never be too thin never be
too pretty
which we're all different so we should
be happy with how we look
and how we are but you know since we
were little that was drilled in our
heads
i think you look so beautiful dolores i
am
so glad that our conversations are
having a positive effect
they are for me too i am 45 and this is
the first time
in my life that i've actually been the
same weight for a year
it's been 20 30 pounds up 20 30 pounds
down
and it just it's probably not the
healthiest
right no it's not healthy for us to cut
and as we get older the yoyoing is even
worse for us
so we are finding the balance together
dolores
i'm so happy to be your partner in this
let's keep going let's
keep checking in let's see if we can
maintain
find joy yes feel like it's worth it
and do this together yes let's do that
you are my partner
in all good balanced crime dolores and i
love you so much and i'm so happy to be
your new bff by the way
i i love you drew i love you too hey
you want to hang out again if you just
hit subscribe
apparently we can